[Music]
[Music]
we are all dancing over here from
performing and touring internationally
publishing books to earning their first
grammy nomination our guests today are
the true definition of a power couple
please welcome husband and wife duo
andres and christina of uno dos tres
andres how are you guys super excited to
be here oh my gosh that music was so fun
let's talk about what you guys do and
how you really brought your talents
together to create this
well we met about 10 years ago we are a
married couple and i was working as a
schoolteacher i was teaching public
school andres was wrapping up his
graduate students studies in music and
we were like why don't we do a band for
kids i love it and so now it's been 10
years we tour all over the country
including here in las vegas we've had
concerts before and uh and now this
grammy nomination our first one oh my
gosh congratulations that is so exciting
for you guys and over the years you have
done so much let's talk about the album
that you have here and just like tell us
a little bit about it and if people
listen what will they feel when they
listen to it absolutely we invite
everybody to listen because there's
something for kids and for adults as
well and in this album we combine
modern latin rhythms from all over latin
america from banda in mexico some good
to rock salsa and we have some legends
there that got together for a cause for
a great cause because we're
the funds that come from activity are
going to colombia to help a foundation
and we're bringing music instruments
we're bringing love and we're all here
together in vegas celebrating that as
well oh my gosh how fun and if that
isn't enough you guys also wrote a few
books tell us about those that's right
we've had the privilege of having a few
of our songs turn into books in spanish
and english and it's so cool to see kids
who are growing up um speaking two
languages learning two languages and
reading two languages so it means so
much you guys are making education fun
and just it makes me wanna dance i
absolutely love it and we can all dance
along this weekend tell us about the
show that you're doing it's tomorrow
right that's right tomorrow in hendon
sun at the water
water street plaza right there music
starts at 10 30 a.m and we're gonna have
four out of the five nominees performing
it's gonna be a love fest for the family
for children so we invite everybody to
come over to henderson and celebrate
with grammy nominees and great music oh
my gosh if that didn't sell you i don't
know what will you guys thank you so
much congratulations on everything the
grammy nomination that is huge and next
time you're in vegas you gotta come back
and see us again okay thank you congrats
again you guys thanks for being here and
on this